>>Jamy: It's all about time.
Good teachers know that
they need to differentiate.
It's just something that we
have to do, but finding the time
and carving that time
out of the day to meet
with those small groups can
be very, very difficult.
>>Jamy: So to have it
actually built into our day
where there's a set
time for half an hour
to pull those small
groups, it's wonderful.
>>So I know that it's working
and I know that there's
so much growth going
on in this class.
We're seeing huge gains, gains
that we wouldn't normally see
with just a whole group
lesson once a day.
>>Cole: Teachers kept coming
to me and saying, "Cole,
we need to have time to be
able to work with these kids
in small groups, but
I have classrooms
of thirty-two to thirty-seven.
How do we do that?
>>Cole: We put our heads
together, we started looking
at the schedule and
providing opportunities
where kids were going to other
places while leaving some
to do some response
to intervention
or small group differentiation
with.
We have our fourth,
fifth and sixth graders
who have the opportunity to,
if they did their homework,
they were doing well,
they got to choose.
This is where the I
Choose comes from.
They got to choose
between going to PE
or computer lab or
library or music.
Now where the teacher
had the I Choose,
they get to take a small group
in which she's identified
or he's identified as needing a
specific skill, then being able
to work with those students
during that last 30 minutes,
where they have specific
skills that we're trying
to progress monitor, benchmark
and move them forward with.
>>Jamy: So in my classroom,
the kids at the end
of our math lesson have
formative assessment
and it's usually four questions,
and it covers the concepts
that we did that day.
And I grade them very quickly
and I'm able to determine
who understood what we were
doing that day and who didn't.
So the kids that got usually
an eighty percent or higher,
they go to their I
Choose for that day.
The kids that didn't
will stay here with me.
>>Alyssa: We do a
pretest and sometimes
if you get one wrong,
she helps you on it.
>>Jamy: Okay, so
I'm here to help.
We're going to play
some blackjack.
And we usually just go over
the same lesson over again.
I take out the manipulatives,
we play games.
It's visual for them
and kinesthetic.
>>Alyssa: Last time 'round I
didn't get the decimals right.
She helped us on the homework
part and she taught us how
to do the decimals
in an easier way.
>>Cole: The teacher I Choose
is actually a great time
to close those skill gaps
and make them proficient
and make them successful,
which makes everyone happy.
The ebb and flow of I Choose
changes every single day based
upon not only the performance,
but how they did in class
and what the teacher feels
is best for the child.
We even have kids in
fifth and sixth grade
who take their half an hour and
their I Choose is going to help
out first graders
in the RTI process,
whether that's doing
flash cards to help them
with their sight words or letter
names or whatever it may be.
The teachers are happy because
they were the push for it.
They were the ones
that wanted the time.
We were able to find
it for them.
What we're hearing from kids
is they absolutely love it.
Byproduct is, they're paying
attention more in class,
they're pushing themselves
to make sure that they get
to choose where they want to go.
Those kids that are struggling,
we're able to now create
proficiency, move them forward.
That's what lets us
know it's working.